Most people know that metal coins won’t
float in water. But for this experiment I’m
going to show you a cool little trick, that’ll
make them look like they do.
For this demonstration you’re going to need
a bowl water, and a handful of 1 yen coins.
1 yen coins are kind of like Japanese pennies,
and there’s a good chance you can get some
if you’re really really nice, to your neighborhood,
Japanese exchange students.
These common coins are around 2.5 times lighter
than our pennies, because they’re minted
from aluminum instead of zinc. But that doesn’t
mean they can float.
In fact if you try tossing a few into a bowl
of water, you’ll see they instantly sink
to the bottom, without hesitation.
But to change all that, you just need one
small paperclip.
Simply unfold the clip by bending the inner
part back until it makes an “L” shape,
then balance one of the coins on the larger
end, and use the other side as a handle to
slowly dip the coin into the water.
Now pull the clip back out of the water, and
amazingly, the coin will be left floating
on top, almost like magic.
It’s kind of like the coin nestles itself
into some kind of invisible force field. Warping
the surface of the water, and denting it down.
What’s really amazing is you can float as
many as you want all at the same time, as
long as they’ll fit in the bowl. But how
does this work?
The answer, is surface tension.
The attraction between the water molecules
at the surface, is just strong enough to support
the weight of an aluminum coin without letting
it break through. It’s kind of like a thin
elastic layer that covers the top.
And it’s a very delicate balance. So as
you might imagine, adding just a touch more
pressure will break the layer for a second,
and let the coins drop back to the bottom again.
Now let’s explore this phenomenon a little
further, and watch what happens if we sprinkle
pepper flakes on the water first.
This time as the weight of the coin warps
the water, you can see the closest flakes
immediately begin attracting toward it, then
stick to the sides.
The mass of the coin creates enough of a disturbance
that any flakes within range eventually get
sucked toward it, until they collide and become
part of the system. Which is the way some
people say gravity works.
That could be the case, because if you try
placing a few coins in close proximity, the
two masses immediately gravitate toward each
other, until they impact, and snap together like magnets.
Now if you really want to try this trick but
can’t find any aluminum coins, don’t worry.
You can still use things like paperclips,
pins, needles and even staples. They’ll
all work just as well, even though they’re
made of steel, and nearly 3 times heavier than aluminum.
Use the same paperclip trick from before,
to quickly and easily set your metal bits floating on their own.
And if you’re careful and have a large enough
dish, you might even be able to get the entire
box of paperclips, floating at once.
Now the idea of floating paperclips isn’t
new, and some of your friends might think
they’re smart because they already know
how it works.
So if you want to mess with their heads a
bit, just pour in a few drops of dish soap
when they’re not looking.
Soap breaks up the surface tension of the
water, and weakens the hydrogen bonds, which
means your victim won’t be able to get a
single paperclip to float, no matter how many
times they try, or how slowly and carefully,
the paperclips are set into place.
Well now you know a cool little trick you
can try at home, at school, or the office,
to impress friends and co-workers, by making
random bits of metal, float on water.
That’s it for now. If you liked this experiment,
perhaps you’ll like some of my others.
Check them out at www.thekingofrandom.com